JON OLSON: My name is Jon
Olson and it is my honor
to introduce Marc
Solomon, National Campaign
Director for Freedom to Marry,
to speak about his new book
"Winning Marriage."
Last April I married my husband
thanks to Marc and his work,
and Freedom to Marry,
and a host of activists
from scores of organizations.
It was a big deal for me and
my husband, and our families
and friends.
But it wasn't political
and subversive,
the way gay marriage used
to be just 10 years ago.
I kept hoping for an
opportunity to be outraged,
but everyone from Medford
City Hall to Crate and Barrel
was just helpful and pleasant.
In Massachusetts gay marriage
is just marriage now,
which is just as it should be.
Marc has received many
honors for his work
on marriage equality,
and Freedom to Marry
keeps winning court
battles, state
by state, across the country.
Amid all that acclaim, my little
voice doesn't amount to much,
but thank you.
Your work is making the
world a better place,
and has made my life better.
Welcome, Marc Solomon.
[APPLAUSE]
MARC SOLOMON: Well,
thank you very much.
It is great to be here.
It's great to be here
for a few reasons.
Number one, Google has been
just an incredible friend
to this cause over
the last decade
while we've been
battling it out.
I remember being in California
during the last couple
weeks of the No On 8 Campaign--
the really devastating campaign
that our side lost-- and no
company was more represented
with respect to loaned staff
and support than Google.
And after amicus brief
Google is always there.
So great thanks,
both to the company
and to the amazing employees
who put so much enthusiasm
into this cause, and it's making
the country a better place.
It's also great being here
in Cambridge, which is really
the cradle of this movement.
I'm probably one of the
few people who sort of gets
choked up when I walk
past Cambridge City Hall,
because that's where
it all started.
That's where this battle-- or
that's at least where marriages
first started, and where
we realized the first winds
from this long, long battle.
I want to thank Jonathan
for welcoming me to Google
and putting this event together.
So I want to talk a little
bit about where we are today,
and how we've gotten here.
My book is really--
"Winning Marriage"--
is really about how
we've gotten here.
But where we are today is
really quite exceptional.
We're not duking it out in
Cambridge, Massachusetts.
Today, the center of the
battle is Birmingham, Alabama.
So we clearly have moved a long
way over the past 11 years.
We have 37 states,
really 37 and 1/2 states,
where same-sex couples can
marry, up from 11 years ago
when we had none.
There was just a
poll released by CNN
that showed that we have 63
percent support nationwide
for marriage equality.
Including 57 percent in the
south, and then from there.
And New England is in
the 70+ percent range.
We've now won 61 lawsuits
in the past year and a half,
or 61 out of about 66, 67.
So we're just on a
tremendous winning streak,
and we're headed to the US
Supreme Court once again.
More cases is
heading up there that
would end all the rest of these
bans, nationwide, on marriage.
Just the other day, Justice
Ruth Bader Ginsburg-- now known
as Notorious RBG-- who's
becoming cooler as she ages,
said, at George
Washington University,
"There hasn't been
any major change
in which there wasn't a
groundswell among the people
before the Supreme Court
put its stamp of approval
on the inclusion and the
equality concept of people
who are left out."
And really that's
where we believe
we are today, that we have
a critical mass of states,
37 states-- which is more than
70 percent of the country--
living in a state where
gay couples can marry.
63 percent support,
solid majority support,
in every part of the country.
And we think America is ready
for national resolution,
and for the Supreme Court to
end the rest of these bans
on marriage, and make
a ruling nationwide.
But, of course as
you all know here,
it hasn't always been that way.
I first got involved
in this fight in 2001
when I was a graduate
student down the street
a little bit at Harvard.
And that was right at
the time that GLAD,
Gay and Lesbian
Advocates and Defenders,
put together a lawsuit.
Seven same-sex couples went
to their town clerk's offices
throughout the state
of Massachusetts.
They applied for a
marriage license.
They were denied the license,
and then GLAD, on their behalf,
went to the Massachusetts
courts to sue.
And I will never, ever
forget November 18, 2003
when I remember I was sitting
at my computer at the Kennedy
School at Harvard at
8:00 in the morning,
and we'd been waiting day after
day after day for a ruling,
for a decision to
finally come down.
And the Supreme Judicial
Court puts on their website
at 8:00 AM which decisions
are coming down at 10:00 AM
that day.
And finally, that
day, November 18th,
it came up Goodridge versus the
Department of Public Health.
And I remember.
So then we all just-- I
was an active volunteer
at that point in this
very grassroots group
called the Massachusetts
Freedom to Marry Coalition
where we would go to prides,
and serve wedding cake,
and do all sorts of public
education, speakers,
bureaus-- real grassroots
organizing and activism.
And I was called at 9:00am that
morning by New England Cable
News, and they asked me if I
would be willing to be on live
as the decision came in to
offer my sort of thoughts,
reflections on the decision.
And the first
thing I remember is
that I was wearing
a really ugly shirt,
and I was like, oh my
God, this is in an hour.
I don't have time to
go home and change.
And I didn't.
And I thought everybody had
forgotten about the shirt
until somebody mentioned
it to me a few months ago.
I was like, I guess not.
But that's not what's important.
I remember getting into a taxi
in Harvard Square at about 9:30
and heading over to Newton
where NECN is based.
And I was on the phone
with the folks at GLAD,
and they had Mary Bonauto
the superstar attorney
who had argued the case in
Massachusetts on speaker phone.
She was down at the
courthouse, and she
was leafing through the opinion,
and she said it's a full win.
And I was immediately
getting out of my taxi,
I was wired up, whisked
into the studio,
and was sitting with
several of the anchors.
And they'd broken in
to broadcast this live
because it was such huge news.
And what I remember
most from that day
was just the unbelievably
powerful response
from our opponents.
And it's important to remember
who our opponents were back
then.
I mean, certainly it was
the Catholic hierarchy,
and the Vatican issued
a strong statement
saying this would
never go into effect.
George W. Bush was one
of the first people
who issued a statement.
He was gearing up
for his reelection.
He said that this
decision is wrong.
It cannot happen.
These rogue judges in
Massachusetts can't do this.
Our then governor,
who we have now
shared with the rest of
the country, Mitt Romney,
said something very similar.
This will never go into
effect in my state.
And certainly the
religious right weighed in.
But I think what's more
important for all of us
to remember is
that it wasn't just
who we think of as the usual
suspects who weighed in
in opposition.
It was mainstream Democrats
across the country
and in Massachusetts.
To give you a stark example,
John Kerry, our US Senator,
came out strongly
against the decision,
and a couple months
later supported
a constitutional
amendment to take it away.
So it was not just Republicans.
It wasn't just conservatives.
It wasn't just the
Catholic church.
It was the whole political
system that was shaking.
The Democrats were terrified
and wouldn't support it.
Republicans thought they
could use this as a weapon,
or some of them at least.
I remember in that two
hours on New England Cable
News, the only person who
said something 100 percent
positive who was a
national political figure
was Barney Frank.
And I realized what a huge,
long way we have to go.
And I'd always been a
political operative,
and you know necessity is
the mother of invention.
And we started pulling
together a campaign
that we called Mass Equality,
and I'm sure some of you
here were involved, in one way
or another, in Mass Equality.
But it was a campaign
to protect the decision.
And what I talk about in my
book, "Winning Marriage"--
which you can see over on that
table or everybody else can
find, I'm sure, on Amazon
or some other great site--
is really how we've won.
And I take you into
the statehouses
around the country--
including the state house here
in Massachusetts where
I spend about 1/3
of the book talking about
the battle in Massachusetts--
into governors' mansions, into
courts, into the White House.
And, more importantly,
into our campaign war rooms
where we built campaigns
to grow and seize power,
take on our opposition,
make our case
for why marriage matters
to same-sex couples,
and make the case to straight
people that this is good.
This is part of the evolution
of the American dream.
It's simply adding another
group into that struggle.
And when I think about
why we've done so well,
I'd say that there are
really two elements to it.
And two elements that our
campaign, our marriage equality
campaigns, have
done really well.
The first is that
we've told our stories.
And I'm sure everybody's
heard that a lot.
It's a building on what
Harvey Milk's admonition
of coming out and sharing
your stories has been.
But we have really had to
take the American people
on a journey to explain
to them who gay people are
and why marriage
is important to us.
Marriage is a very
important institution
to the American people.
And whether or not they practice
what they preach with respect
to marriage, and even
if they don't live up
to people's view of marriage,
it's still something
that people hold
as very important.
And what they wanted to know
was that same-sex couples
were going to treat
marriage with respect,
and not try to undermine
it or uproot it.
And it might sound crazy
today, but that really
has been at the heart of
this battle, is to show
why gay people want to marry.
Why marriage is important to us.
And to do it in a very
local kind of way.
Just to go back, because I
found this speech so profound--
or her talk so profound-- Ruth
Ginsburg, Justice Ginsburg,
the other day said, when she
was asked why she thinks things
have changed so much,
she said, "People
who once hid what they were
have announced to the world,
this is what I am.
And we look to
see what they are,
and they turned out to be
our next door neighbor,
of whom we're very fond.
It turned out to be our child's
best friend, or perhaps even
our child.
I think that accounts for
the very swift change."
And I think there's a lot of
truth in what she's saying,
but what's important is
that gets at a piece of it.
But the hard work behind
telling our stories
is what I think we've
done so effectively.
It's really challenging,
really difficult,
to share the story of who
you are with family members
when you're afraid
you might be rejected.
Or with neighbors
when you don't know
how they're going to
respond and you still
have to live next door to them.
With your legislator
when the last thing
most people want to do is to
sit down and talk about anything
personal with their legislator.
Particularly not in the
Cambridges and Bostons,
but out in rural Massachusetts
and in rural parts
of any state, and
working-class communities.
And so I wanted to share
a story of one couple
from Massachusetts
who did this work so
profoundly and
effectively, but who
are the last couple you would
expect to do this kind of work.
So, and I'm going to read
a little bit from the book
and follow their
story through it.
In the rural town of Charlton
in southern Worcester County,
Deb Grzyb and Sharon
Murphy were pondering
what to do about the Mass
Equality organizer who
was asking them to meet with
their senator, Steve Brewer.
Charlton was only 53
miles from Boston,
but culturally it couldn't
have been more different.
It was the country.
Pickup trucks with gun racks
cruising over the narrow roads
that wound through the wooded
terrain, and American flags
everywhere, including
on Deb and Sharon's
small but
beautifully-adorned home.
The two were the most
unlikely activists.
They'd just celebrated their
25th anniversary together.
But until they'd
married the year before,
they'd told next to no one that
they were lesbian or a couple.
In fact, a few days after
they applied for their wedding
license, they each raced
around the state coming out
to family members--
including Sharon to her mom
and siblings--
because they learned
the local paper was going to
print the names of all those
who had applied.
They were glad
there were activists
who fought for equality
for gay people,
but that simply
wasn't who they were.
The Mass Equality
organizer was persistent,
explaining how critical
it was for legislators
to hear from married couples
who were their own constituents.
Their rural district
was one where
you had next to no advocates, so
they were especially critical.
They finally relented
and agreed to set up
a meeting with their senator
when he was in their community.
So now I'm going to fast-forward
to a meeting with their state
representative, a conservative
Democrat named Paul Kujawski,
whose vote was crucial.
So this was at a meeting
that their pastor set up,
and so their representative,
Kujawski, said,
as the meeting reached
the two-hour mark-- Paul
Kujawski became curious
to know about the lesbian
couple in the room.
He'd been told there was one
married couple in the group.
Well, who was the gay
couple here, he asked.
Sharon and Deb each said, me.
Pointing, Kujawski said, oh, I
thought you two were together.
Deb was sitting next
to a straight woman,
not next to Sharon.
So are you married,
Kujawski asked.
Yes we are, Sharon said.
But when did you get married?
July 12, 2004, she responded.
Where did you get married?
Oh, we got married in the
Headlands in Rockport.
Kujawski was doing his
best to engage them,
but they were reticent.
Pastor John, the clergyman who
put this together, gave Sharon
a gentle pat on her arm and
said, tell him your story.
Sharon proceeded to talk
for 10 minutes about she
and Deb, how she and Deb met
27 years before in Boston.
They knew they were in love,
and moved in together in Dudley
soon after.
Growing up as a child,
she said, you always
think that someday
you'll get married.
And then when you realize who
you are and the way the world
is, you realize that,
well, that might never
be an option for me.
She talked about how she
and Deb lived quietly
first in Dudley, and then up the
road eight miles in Charlton,
and created a life together,
but that something was missing.
She told Kujawski about
their wedding day,
about how they took their
vows overlooking the Atlantic
Ocean in Rockport, and how much
that day and their marriage
mattered to them.
For the first time, they were
legally related to one another.
All we want is what
everyone else has, she said.
We don't want anything more,
but we don't want anything less,
either.
Everyone was listening
with rapt attention,
and Deb had tears
streaming down her face.
Paul Kujawski just sat there
listening, staring, appearing
a bit dumbfounded.
This was a lot different from
what he'd expected to hear.
The people he knew of who
were gay seemed like loners.
He'd never seen
them with anybody,
and he'd never thought
of it as a way of life.
Kujawski was captivated by
the experience of two women
from backgrounds like his own.
Deb had grown up
in a Polish family
in Dudley, the neighboring city
to his hometown of Webster.
He was impressed by
Sharon's strength,
and was sure of their
love for one another
after 27 years together.
All of a sudden, what had seemed
like a black and white decision
on the marriage question
turned stark gray.
His heart felt heavy.
Wow, why didn't you say
that sooner, Kujawski asked.
One of the last to
leave the meeting,
Kujawski told Sharon
and Deb that he'd
like to speak to them
again at some point.
As he left the home
and walked to his car,
his friend Mark, who
had hosted the meeting,
thought it looked as if
the weight of the world
was on the shoulders.
Deb and Sharon sent Kujawski a
follow-up letter the next day
to thank him.
They said they'd
be happy to have
more conversations with him.
So over the course of
the next few months,
and this was in 2007
when we were trying
to get our crucial
vote in Massachusetts--
we needed 3/4 of the legislature
to vote our way-- we had
about 20 targets we were working
on to get over that mark,
they ended up
meeting with Kujawski
at least a couple more times.
And Mass Equality, we worked
on him pretty relentlessly
using every lever that we could.
So this is the day of the vote.
The final vote in Massachusetts.
Early that morning,
Kujawski saw himself
on the front page
of the Boston Globe,
to which he'd given an interview
about his own thought process.
A legislator finds himself
tugged in two directions,
it was called.
It talks about his meetings
with his priests, the governor,
and the Speaker of the House.
It said that Kujawski
appeared to be
headed towards a
change of heart,
and mentioned Sharon and Deb,
who endured so many struggles
and are now so happy together.
It quoted Kujawski as saying,
"Am I going to take that away?"
Heading north and then
east for the 56-mile drive,
Kujawski was resolute that
he was doing the right thing.
If I were gay, he thought, how
would I want to be treated?
And how could I
vote to treat anyone
else differently from that?
It was the real-life
stories that he'd heard,
especially that of Sharon and
Deb, that made him understand.
He figured no one
had approached him
in the past because of his
reputation as a conservative,
but no matter.
Now he got it.
And then this is
right after the votes.
Deb and Sharon saw
Kujawski in the statehouse.
Kujawski walking down
the corridor towards them
with a giant grin on his face.
Sharon hugged and kissed
him, and, through the tears,
thanked him for everything.
Kujo, which was his nickname,
gave Deb a giant bear hug.
The tears were flowing,
and they were all so happy.
You made the difference
for me, Kujawski told them.
After more tears
and embraces, they
got an onlooker to snap a few
pictures of them all together.
So that's the power
of the personal story,
and we, as a campaign, have
done that with legislator
after legislator
in Massachusetts.
And then in every part
of the country that's
been at the heart of
explaining this cause
to the American people
and to our lawmakers--
Is really opening up
and sharing the crux
of our personal stories,
and explaining why
marriage is important to us.
And as people saw that,
as marriages began here
in Massachusetts and
then around the country,
people really started
to understand.
Gay people want to marry for the
same reasons anyone else does.
It's not a bad thing.
It's actually a fine
thing and a good thing,
and let's let it happen.
But it took some
really hard work
and some really
challenging conversations,
people stepping out
of their comfort zone,
in order to make that case.
So if that's, in some
ways, the softer side
of how we've evolved
the country on marriage,
the harder side is
that we've put together
some really smart campaigns
here in Massachusetts
and around the country.
Since I am here north
of the Charles River,
one of the stories I
talk about in the book
is the story of Carl Sciortino,
who some of you may know,
who was a state representative
in Massachusetts.
But just to take a step back,
the one truism about politics
is that, for elected
officials, the thing that's
most important to
an elected official
is continuing to be
an elected official.
And if they think that a
vote is going to cost them
their career, and if you're
banking on them taking a vote
that they think is going
to cost them their career
in order to win, you're
not going to win.
That's is just the
way things are.
And, initially here
in Massachusetts,
people thought that
a vote for marriage
would cost them their career.
And that's been the
case, not just here,
but all over the country.
And we had to turn
that on its head,
but we had to do it first
here in Massachusetts.
And what that meant is that
every person who voted our way,
we had to work hard to
reelect to the legislature.
And in legislatures
around the country,
there's some good folks,
there's some mediocre folks,
there's some corrupt
folks, there's some people
with personal problems.
You get the full
gamut of humanoids
in these state legislatures.
But it didn't matter.
If they voted our way
we had to do everything
we could to get them reelected.
And the biggest thing
that we could do,
the thing that could really
turn things on its head,
would be to defeat a couple of
lawmakers who voted against us.
Then you would really start
getting people's attention.
That not only is this
a safe political cause,
but it's dangerous
to vote against us.
And that was the story of Carl
Sciortino, who some of you
may know.
You might have
seen his ad when he
was running for
Congress recently
with this Tea Party father.
That was a really
terrific political ad.
But he was a
25-year-old graduate
of Tufts University, headed
up the LGBT group at Tufts,
and met with his state
lawmaker, who was
really terrible on marriage.
He kept saying you people,
you people, you people.
And Carl was so annoyed
and really angry
that he said, look,
we've got to find someone
to run against this guy.
And he went out and talked
to-- and his legislature was
a Democrat from
Medford Somerville-- he
went out and talked to
other elected officials,
said hey-- and other
activists-- and said, hey,
would you run against this guy?
Nobody would do it, and
he's like, screw it.
I'll do it myself.
And I've got to be
honest, when I first
met with Carl-- who is now
one of my closest friends--
when I first met with him and
I was like, this is great.
Good luck.
25 gay guy from Tufts.
Go knock on doors and see.
It wasn't until I really
looked at his campaign plan,
and met with this
campaign consultants,
and saw the polling, and saw
how vulnerable his opponent was
that I was like,
this could really--
if we all do this smartly--
this could really happen.
And, in the end, Carl did a
great job in that election.
And he defeated the
16-year incumbent who
was one of the-- he was a
member of leadership, important
to the House Speaker, who was
then virulently against us-- he
defeated him by about 90 votes.
And I remember a week
after that election
a friend of mine who was a
lobbyist in the state house
called me and said I was
just in the restroom,
and I overheard these two
conservative lawmakers
talking to one another.
And they said, hey, did you
hear what the gays did to Vinny?
That was the guy
that Carl defeated.
And when I heard that
story, I was like, wow,
we really are getting somewhere.
We're starting to
show our power.
And so we've put together
a smart-- We did it here.
We reelected, in Massachusetts,
195 out of 195 incumbents
who voted our way.
We didn't lose any
race in 2004 and 2006.
That was in spite of the
fact that Mitt Romney
tried his hardest to
elect more Republicans
to the legislature, the
vast majority of whom--
back then-- were against us.
We spent well over
a million dollars.
We did millions of
pieces of direct mail.
We polled in dozens
and dozens of races.
And that's been one of
the tenets of our work
around the country, is putting
together smart campaigns.
And knowing that
we have to operate
both in the political
system and in the political
climates in which we are.
So there's some really sleazy
state capitals out there.
I had the good fortune
of spending several weeks
in Albany, New York, which is
just really a terrible place.
Not the city so much,
but the politics
are just really grim there.
And they call it a
transactional state capitol,
and you don't even want to
know what that really means.
But we put together
a sharp campaign
and partnered up
with Governor Cuomo,
who was a powerful advocate.
We, as a community, had been
involved in the elections
there.
And we pulled that one
out in spite of the fact
that both Republican
leadership in the state Senate
and Democratic leadership
we're trying to,
for various reasons, trying
to torpedo the marriage bill.
Springfield, Illinois
was the same way.
Also an incredibly
sleazy state capitol.
Except there are pictures and
photos and statues of Abraham
Lincoln all over, looking
over your shoulder
as these lawmakers are trying
to do some less than above-board
things.
And after 2008 in
California when
we have that devastating
loss of Proposition 8,
which truly was a horrible,
awful thing that was--
and it was a real body
blow to our movement
and to our community.
For me, it was such a body
blow that I picked up,
I came back to Massachusetts,
left Mass Equality,
moved to California to put
together a ballot campaign
to win marriage back.
It eventually got won
back through the courts,
and I left and joined
Freedom to Marry.
But I knew it was so
profoundly devastating.
And that we, the
spirit of our community
and the spirit of this
battle for marriage,
wouldn't come back until
we'd won marriage back
in California.
But what we did is we
didn't just sit there.
We spent the next few
years figuring out
how to win at the ballot.
And in 2012 we did
finally win at the ballot
after 33 losses in a row.
We won at the ballot in
four states, four out
of four, in November of 2012,
in Washington, and Minnesota,
and Maryland, and Maine.
And we did it by
figuring out better
how to talk about
marriage, and really
how to run smart,
strategic campaigns.
So running smart
campaigns has also
been at the heart of this fight.
And even and through getting
President Obama to evolve
on marriage, and
we ran a campaign
to put a Freedom to Marry plank
in the Democratic platform
in 2012-- which gave a
lot of the Obama folks
and a lot of Democrats
a lot of heartburn.
But we pushed, and he did the
right thing, and was then-- he
and the party were incredibly
proud of what that meant,
and what that did for
him and his legacy
and for his ability to
reach out to younger voters.
So if the two keys to this,
and I'm only touching on them,
but if the two keys to winning
were telling our stories
and explaining to
the American people
why marriage was
so important to us,
and explaining the
integrity-- and showing
the integrity-- of
our relationships,
and then running hard,
tough, smart campaigns--
I think a little bit
about what inspired
me to write this book in
the middle of this fight.
When I started
writing, we really
were in the middle
of this fight.
We're hopefully getting
closer to the end now,
but there are
really two reasons.
And the first reason I decided
to write "Winning Marriage"
is because the cause of civil
rights is a very lofty cause.
And it is profound, and
lofty, and high minded,
but what I really
wanted to do was
show the work of civil rights.
And the work of civil rights
is not lofty work in the main.
It is going out and
knocking on doors.
Not in Cambridge, but going
out to far out communities
in Middlesex County and out to
Worcester and rural Worcester
County.
And out away from New York City
into the suburban-- and not
just suburban communities-- but
into smaller cities and towns.
And in California,
it's organizing
in the Central Valley, in
Fresno and Bakersfield,
and Orange County.
It's having tough conversations
in parts of the community,
in parts of the geography
that don't feel as safe
and that aren't as supportive.
That's the work
of this movement.
When I think about all the
canvassers and organizers
I've had working for me
now in the last 11 years,
I've had hundreds and
hundreds of organizers,
who are just amazing, work
and take this work on.
And I bet there have been
at least 10 dog bites.
And I know that there have
been many more people who
have been chased down
the streets by homophobes
in different communities.
And that's the hard
work of civil rights.
It's giving to a
political candidate who
your state-wide LGBT
group says is important
because they voted your way.
Even if you don't know
who that person really is.
Or going out and knocking
on doors for that candidate.
And it is having those
tough conversations
that you feel like,
oh my God, I finally
need to have this
conversation with this family
member or this neighbor, or
need to have a little house
party in my neighborhood
to explain why this is
important to me and my partner
when, for so many years,
we've been living with our heads
down because-- let's face it--
we don't want to create waves.
We don't want people
to come after us.
We don't want to be attacked.
That's been the
heart of this work.
And it continues.
That's the work that's happening
today in Texas, and in Alabama,
and throughout the South.
So I did want to show, really,
the nuts and bolts of what
these campaigns are about
and the hard, hard work that
has gone into them.
And also the thing that's really
exciting about our success
is that I-- and the other reason
I wanted to write this book--
is I wanted to provide
something of a road map
for other social movements.
I mean, there are so many
causes in our country
that are really
stagnating right now.
And our cause, the marriage
cause, has done quite well.
And I don't pretend to have
all the answers for all causes
in the lease, but I do think
that over the last decade
of trial and error and losing
and losing and then winning,
and figuring things out,
I think we have learned
some important things
that we can share
with other social movements.
Whether it's economic
inequality, or gun violence
prevention, or global warming.
And one of the really
exciting things
these days is that I am asked to
speak to other social movements
and other groups who are leading
social movements about how
we've done and how the
marriage movement has done it,
and what we can teach.
So that really feels great
to be able to do that.
And I guess I want to conclude
with a little bit about where
we are in this fight right now.
So I said we are, literally
and metaphorically, we're
on the steps of the
US Supreme Court.
And we are close, we
hope, to final resolution.
But I want to caution
all of us that one
of things I hear
now, so often, is
that this cause is inevitable.
It's done.
It's over.
And when I think back
to when I first started,
when I first was
going to those prides,
and serving wedding cake, and
making the case for marriage--
first to LGBT people,
and then to progressives,
and then further out,
reaching out to Republicans--
people were saying,
this is crazy.
This is impossible.
I would go to Club Cafe and
meet up with my friends there,
and they'd be like,
what are you doing?
Working on gay marriage?
This is never going to happen.
You're just pissing off
the Catholic church.
And so the pitch
was, it's impossible.
And I was thinking about
how much commonality
there is between the
impossible and inevitable.
And what really brings
those two things together,
or what's really the
same about those two,
is they both allow
you to sit around.
If something's impossible,
why would do Anything
it's just impossible.
And if it's
inevitable, same thing.
It's going to happen anyway.
Why would I get up
and do something?
And I guess, number one,
the work of social movements
and the work of causes that
are big and worth fighting
for is the work of taking
something that feels,
to so many people, impossible,
and making progress
every single day.
Building momentum
every single day,
until the point where we are
today where so many people are
saying now it's inevitable.
But what I'd say, I would
also say it's not inevitable.
I mean, very little
is inevitable.
It's not like we have a nine
to nothing majority on the US
Supreme Court.
And our job over
the next few months,
and what we're working
on, literally, right now,
is making the
strongest presentation
we can to the US Supreme
Court that America
is ready for
national resolution,
and it's time to finish the job.
And I am one who
would-- I end up
using lots of sports analogies.
We should never spike the
ball on the 10-yard line.
We've got to leave
it all on the field.
We just have to keep going
hard until the court rules.
And if they rule
our way then we can
have lots and lots
of big parties
and celebrate that it
actually is inevitable
because it's done.
But until it's done,
it's not yet done.
And we do have 70
percent of the country
where gay people can
marry, but I was just
out in Columbus, Ohio last week.
And Ohio's a state where
there is not yet the freedom
to marry.
And they certainly
don't think it's done.
And we have organizers on the
ground in Texas and in Alabama.
And in Texas they certainly
don't think it's done.
So there's still
work to be done.
The cause isn't over yet.
We need to fight
through the finish line.
So I guess I would and there.
And, again, I want to thank
our friends at Google.
When I think about how
politicians are often
about a decade behind
where the public is,
corporations have been really
helping guide this fight.
And it's companies
like Google that
have been showing politicians
and others that not only is it
safe to be in favor of
the freedom to marry,
but it's actually good business.
So thanks to all of you.
Thanks for coming.
And I look forward to chatting,
answering any questions,
and signing books,
and hanging out.
MALE SPEAKER: I have a question.
From your experience--
one of the things that
worries me about America today
is the enormous influence
of money in politics, the
vast corruption of our system,
is there anything to
be done about that?
How do we get money
out of politics?
MARC SOLOMON: That's
a good question.
So I'd say there's
sort of two answers.
I mean, on the first--
right now, as you know
and as you stated,
there are huge amounts
of money in politics.
And so, from my vantage
point, we have to,
in the marriage
movement, we've certainly
had to play by the
rules that we have.
And so we have
used as much money
as we can get our hands
on to make the case
and to win elections.
But now with these just
ridiculous amounts of money,
when you read something
like the Koch brothers
are going to spend $900 million
in this next presidential
election cycle, it's
just outrageous.
I think that it's very, very
difficult because the court has
ruled that money is speech.
And, from my vantage
point, it's not speech.
Money is money.
And money is influence.
It's not simply speech.
So I guess there are
a couple answers.
One is work to elect
a president who
will appoint Supreme Court
justices who don't believe
that money is speech.
And, second, there are
efforts to start building
towards a constitutional
amendment.
That's going to be
a long, long road.
So that's going
to be a tough one.
But there are some good
people working on this cause.
And so I don't have
a-- there's certainly
no simple answer to that one.
But those are a couple.
Do you have a second question?
You don't have to.
MALE SPEAKER: With
respect to climate change,
which is something that
worries me very much--
MARC SOLOMON: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: I was
thinking about how
to apply your lessons in
the space of climate change,
but the personal stories
are a lot harder to come by.
I don't get to marry
a polar bear, so
what-- can you paint a
little more of a picture
about how your
techniques pertain
to a more abstract issue
like climate change?
MARC SOLOMON: Yeah,
I mean, I think
the more we can make it
local, any cause local,
the better off we are.
On LGBT rights and
on marriage equality,
when we first started
working on it,
people were talking about--
when we'd do focus groups
and we'd watch people and
they'd talk about those people
out there-- those people in
San Francisco, those people
in New York-- not people
right here at home.
So I haven't spent a
lot of time focused
on how to make the
case on climate change,
but I think making it
as local as possible
and having people talk
about local impact,
so how's it going to
affect Boston, how's
it going to affect our
children living here in Boston,
is really important.
That's the-- I think it's,
from my vantage point,
it's got to be about people
as opposed to polar bears,
even though they're cute.
I think to the extent we can
talk about how it is affecting
people, and how it's
affecting our kids,
I think that's the way to do it.
Those are just a
couple thoughts.
And I would love to sit down
and plot with some of my friends
who are working on this issue.
But those are a couple thoughts.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]